salut à tous les amis c'est fabien
olicard castel j'espère que vous les
avez bien à côté ça super ou coup voilà
c'était l'intro d'aujourd'hui j'aime
c'est un trop parce qu'il ya la moitié
des gens qui adorent ça et le shit
rossum malaise en ile et vendredi nous
sommes vendredi les six heures vous avez
entendu ce bug que je viens juste de
faire parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est une
vidéo concept c'est pas un gros concept
le concept c'est vous qui l'avait
proposée dans les commentaires j'ai
trouvé ça cool c'est de se dire je serai
bien est ce que tu peux essayer de faire
une clé au casse-tête non-montée
pourvoir et bo kay celle ci sera pas
monter sauf peut-être la phase de
résolution à un moment donné si ça met
trop de temps mais je pense que ça
prendra du temps mais qui a pas besoin
de recherche particulière quand je
regarde ça peut-être y aura un accélérer
le hic sera autorisé à faire un
excellent et l'on monte ça veut pas dire
non travaillées cette magnifique
colorimétrie waouh c'est fait sans
réalisé par loïc un indice se trouve ici
c'était ça se souvient rien je ne sais
jamais ce qui peut faire au montage et
et puis voilà écoutez c'est parti on à
l'anneau de moyens bus en fait je veux
juste acheté parce que je kiffe le
concept de base de l'anonymat
si vous connaissez pas voici une image
ici de l'anneau c'est une manière de
tourner un ruban pour faire en sorte que
ce ruban avec une seule phase c'est un
peu dingue deuxième et si vous mettez le
doigt à l'extérieur du ruban et que vous
suivez toujours
l'expérience du ruban que vous allez
faire aussi tout l'intérieur
démonstration avec ceux ci le point et
là j'imagine je pars d'ici qu'elle je
suis un peu à l'intérieur du ruban et
pourtant je suis à l'extérieur et je
suis à l'extérieur mais la regarde et je
suis aussi par l'intérieur et là
j'arrive ici je veux pas continuer en
fait c'est infini c'est à ruban à une
seule phase j'ai enfin moi je trouve ça
dingue et ils ont eu la bonne idée d'en
faire un casse tête où il faut libérer
cette sorte de pièce
donc je vais essayer ça j'aime bien en
plus il a un style un peu steampunk
évidemment on a envie de bourriner gens
sortir là donc comme c'est un anneau de
mouillage bus un ruban une seule face à
dire que si je suis tout le même tour un
moment donné il va se retrouver ici
juste là et non pas ici tu sais pas si
c'est bien clair mais je vais je vais je
vais essayer de faire ça je vais essayer
de partir donc ici je me retrouve
bloquée parce qu'en même temps il faut
que je prenne en compte ce côté là ok
c'est ça je pense pas que ça mérite
d'accélérer la vidéo dans la découverte
de l'objet mais par contre par contre je
vous le dis ça peut être long ou pas
parce qu'en fait comme c'est un casse
tête et par rapport à la philosophie
mais qu'ils pensaient d'une philosophie
des casse-têtes pas par une philosophie
que j'ai des casse tête il faut pouvoir
l'enlever et leur met aussi dans sa
position initiale le remettre une
saloperie l'accent rochelais qui fait
que quand il ya deux consonnes suivi
d'un e
j'ai tendance à dire intro genre
première relier deux premières je sais
je me rends compte c'est hyper rhône où
j'ai tourné la récemment le la version
audio de mon livre ça sortira en fin
d'année je crois et donc c'était plus de
quinze heures d'enregistrement et je me
suis fait reprendre je connais
maintenant mais trois grands tic mauvais
tics de langage qui sont de dire
première ou un s au lieu d'un x genre
dans explications de d'explication et
c'était quoi le troisième truc
ah oui maintenant lieu de maintenant
justement ça me tarde t et ça c'est
vraiment un petit accent de la rochelle
et ça fait bien bien plaisir d'avoir des
origines rochelaise mais par contre
quand je décide en livres en audio etc
entreprend toutes les deux phrases et un
peu webber il y avait aussi un petit
truc j'ai tendance à dire 'ben au lieu
de bonnes genre disons que la tarte que
m'a faite ma mère allez bonne et bien
non elle est bonne bonne alors je
croyais avoir fait le tour mais pas du
tout je vais le reste à quai par là pour
voir si je peux pas passer par en hausse
le pas et un rang du bas village
ok je passe par en bas mais en fait du
coup ça me fait ça me fait rater le
coche
là si je remonte par au dessus à partir
de maintenant puisque je veux refaire
encore tout autour ça va me faire passer
si je passe par au dessus ou en dessous
donc je vais partir mais pas en dessous
quoi qu'est ce que je peux repasser par
là comme ça
à oui peut-être a atteint en fait juste
là on a ça qui va bloquer mais de ce
côté là mais qu'est ce qui bloque
eh bien oui c'est celui derrière qui
belote est-ce que je peux attaquer plus
haut à la
elle sait pas si simple parce que y'a
qu'une face et du cou il ya un indien
entier sur la face mais comme la façon
l'attaquent recto verso
s'il n'a aucun sens avec le aux côtés du
mot phase qui est une phase i à pattes
avec lorie reçoit me voyez très bien de
ce dont je parle et fait pas semblant
pas comprendre il faut que je prenne les
devants compte en même temps vous savez
je vous ferai vraiment un gros plans
bien badass bien stylé de tout ce
casse-tête sur instagram comme d'hab
oui j'ai dans la description où il est
là mon instinct oui j'en parle quasiment
à chaque vidéo parce qu'à chaque vidéo
que j'en parle je me rends compte que
vous êtes des centaines à venir donc
peut-être vous saviez pas qu'elle
instagram est peut-être vous pouvez me
rejoindre c'est là que je suis le plus
actif de facebook twitter et snap aussi
mais j'avoue qu'en ce moment je me
prends plutôt des touches sur un site à
mais j'oublie pas le pont neuf alors je
suis en train de faire un truc qui est
pas bien de faire je suis en train
d'insister au même endroit en fait c'est
une erreur de ma part
donc je vais contournée par ça qui me
remet donc en temps normal dessus
intéressant si je fais ça je dois
pouvoir remplacer par
oui cent mille votes la tête
peut-être qu'au moment où je vous parle
il y aura eu des coupes parce que j'ai
l'impression que ça va être long et du
coup la vidéo concept n'est plus du tout
un concept
c'est possible ok voilà c'est exactement
ce que je voulais parce que ça te faire
repasser par là non parce qu'en fait je
crois je pense 1 je pense que ma sortie
elle est ici entre lui et lui et c'est
ce qui me fera passer là je ne crois pas
du tout que ça vienne de l'autre côté du
coup il faudrait peut-être que je passe
par en bas
d'abord ensuite remonté remontée non
si non haddad la totalité joue au
millimètre laisser des psychopathes un
les gens qui créent ce genre de choses à
hasnon en tout cas si c'est ma sortie je
vois pas comment l'atteindre
du coup qu'est ce qui bloque la non mais
je suis redevenu à la position où je
m'étais avait déjà bloqué tout à l'heure
j'ai un train d'insister sur la même
méthode c'est à vous ça va bien alors
c'est super parce que là en fait je les
ai bien remis dans sa position de départ
si vous aviez si vous n'aviez pas eu le
début de la vidéo
voilà la position de départ c'est hyper
important de la connaître parce que
sinon on a tendance à pas faire
attention à ce qu'on fait mais en fait
ce que je veux dire c'est qui ça c'est
la position de l'état alors ça ça ne
marche pas mon idée toutefois que le ps
et même celle ci la position de départ
chez ake l'enfer en fait c'est
exactement bon si lui il était tourné
complètement dans l'autre sens en fait
ok donc j'étais partie par la gauche au
premier coup alors ce coup ci je vais
partir par la droite
je vais rester en haut le plus souvent
possible et quand c'est plus possible je
vais switcher par le bas peut-être qu'en
faisant ça par le bas comme ça non plus
je suis obligé de revenir par le hockey
du coup je vais revenir maintenant par
le haut
plus souvent possible et ensuite
descendre par le bas j'hésite à mettre
cette vidéo là en post est en podcast
audio
je pense qu'elle serait vraiment
passionnante à écouter dans sa voiture
donc non je suis en train de faire part
il faut que je progresse par là aussi
passé comme ça pas mal mon fab
oui mais je m'encourage parce que je
vous entends pas dans les commentaires
qu'est ce que vous voulez je vous dise
pourquoi je peux pas y a pas un bypass
par là qu est ce qu un bypass dans un
casse tête
c'est d'une manière de prendre un
raccourci si je le prends là et je fais
ici ne lâcheront pas leur manquer la
vérité c'est pas sympa on avait
tellement bien la volonté de vérité en
est à combien de temps loïc sécher 45 et
avec combien de temps tu sur ta carte sd
passe 48 c'est vrai tu te fous de moi je
vais remonter un petit peu remonté tu
que je remonte des choses en gironde ces
feux sont la justice il a en fait de
l'autre côté il ya cinq une crèche
et vraiment je comprends pas pourquoi il
veut pas me le faire passer là parce que
franchement franchement ce serait sympa
comme cdc bien voulu me faire passer si
je le perds c'est beau hein lannoy et
bus c'est vraiment ça magnifique objet
mais alors vraiment là ça en train de me
péter la tête
en fait je peux pas faire mes schémas de
logique habituelle at il à un check
point qui bloque ses ennemis d'allah
j'étais passé le pas le plus souvent
possible donc je vais essayer de passer
par le pôle solutions possibles qui veut
dire qu'elle la mer j'ai pas voir le
choix ici
est-ce que là je peux faire un retour
non ici d'ac dc on peut pas celle à toi
sinon que des nouvelles la famille tous
à cela ouais ça va ça va ça va tamer ça
va un peu les toits sa voix est assez m6
à abdel et là ça va c'est là qu'ils
avaient accéléré qu'on le veuille ou non
chose donc je l'imaginé forcément accès
à
ça rend fou ce que vraiment je comprends
pas ou qu'est ce qu'il ya
[Musique]
comme ça
en fait la toute fin il faut repartir
par là par le bas absolument
jusque là est remonté pour le reprendre
ici à l'envers et c'est ici le seul
chemin de seul trajet par lequel on
puisse passer il est juste là c'est
celui ci fallait viser et tu peux
l'avoir quand vous en aller retour
c'est à dire un peu plus loin c'était là
voilà c'est à dire quand tu viens dit si
tu viens de là donc là il est mis dans
la position des bains on arrive par là
et devant les trois ans l'escalier on
remonte l'escalier et on passe ici et là
on arrive à le contrôler ouf
il est trop cool voyez j'ai compris
c'est cool je voulais hormis dans sa
position de départ les amis très
chouette
il rentre dans mon top favori des casse
têtes on va pas se mentir
j'aime lanouaille bus il j'ai bien aimé
le côté labyrinthe un peu mine de thor
dedans j'ai bien aimé que ça me fasse
galéré que je comprenne que tardivement
ou est-ce qu'il fallait leur tour faire
leur tour et c'était sur la petite zone
où il y en a trois en escalier c'est à
dire non c'est pas celle ci c'est celle
ci c'est celle qui est intérieure cc3
petit escalier là si jamais vous le
faites mais comme vous l'aimez vous
ferez les jolies bien badass pour bien
vous faire voir sa sueur pour bien vous
faire ça si je instagram
oui j'ai fait tomber des choses c'est
pour ça que ça fait claque comme ça je
crois ne rien avoir oublié de vous dire
dans cette vidéo si ce n'est que
effectivement pour voir le spectacle en
tournée vous regardez il ya le lien dans
la description il ya plus de 40 villes
c'est le lien vers mon psy une carte
interactive vous avez un moteur de
recherche extrêmement simple moi ça m'a
fait plaisir de vous voir aujourd'hui
peut-être qu'il y aura encore des vidéos
bonus avant celle de mercredi prochain 6
heures n'oubliez pas de vous abonner en
cliquant ici de regarder la dernière
vidéo qui est sortie n'ont même pas je
vous mettre celle des castels de la
semaine dernière avec le des pièces
d'échecs parce que la semaine prochaine
nous allons faire la suite
à très bientôt bike et je vous aime tous
bravo femme et qu'en même temps une
heure